They're trying to get rid of, uh, uh, how about the lady that was on?
What was it? Good morning America or no, it was a British show. Right?
How do I pull that up? Where she was trying to get rid of clapping?
Get batting clapping. Good morning, Britain. Basic.
Good morning, Britain. Subasic
Gore morning. Good morning. Why can't I say it, dude.
Brattain here we go. Should we ban clapping? Good morning. Britain
victorious. The song.
Let's take the serious side of this first. What is upsetting?
Genuinely about clapping. Okay.
Nothing. There you go. And there is something about clapping nothing.
And thank you. I'll wait for my that's.
How that should add [inaudible] right there. And then right here, there's our.
The serious side of this first.
What is upsetting genuinely about clapping? Nothing.
No thing. Oh, absolutely. Nothing. That's hard to get away.
Let's take this serious. I want to do it again because I'm annoying.
What is upsetting genuinely about clapping?
Absolutely.
[inaudible] Oh. That's funny, dude. Anyway, so this is what, this is what it is,
what it does.
What is upsetting?
So it's actually not just in people with anxiety. It's also.
So it's actually like, it's actually not just people with anxiety.
People who use hearing AIDS, copping can be disruptive to that,
but it's also people who use hearing AIDS. Clapping could be disruptive to that.
People have sensory processing issues.
It can be very distressing and overwhelming to have those loud sudden noises.
But it is part of our culture.
Go. Let's just so far. I agree with both of them.
Let's see how it derails.
The isn't it to clap. If you go to the thing.
Look at this, look at how look I love when people try to be diplomatic about,
about something,
but it's impossible to make them not sound like and not feel like an idiot.
Why it's a bit like part of like the culture, right?
When we go to the theater, you're going to expect to hear clapping right now.
I don't mean that you're a piece of when I say that,
but it's literally,
it's virtually impossible for me to not make you seem like a piece of, right?
Because I'm saying something that's so obvious. You're not mine. Anyway,
go ahead. Expand on that.
Culture. Isn't it to clap.
If you go to the theater or you go to a lecture or you go to a performance or
you go to a gig, you would expect that people would clap. Yeah,
absolutely. And that could be preventing people from going to those events.
I agree with both of them and we're, you know,
37 in and, and your boy agrees with both of them, dude.
So this is great, man.
Which is a real shame. So if some.
Oh wait, hold on.
And that could be preventing people from going to those events. Oh, okay.
Which is a real shame.
I picked the side.
Too. If some theaters or some university.
I took a step on over to the other side. I took a step. Okay.
Maybe I got another foot. I'm like, well,
let's see what this other lady has to say.
Let's do more with this lady has to date. Maybe I'll call back.
Do you know what I'm saying? We'll see.
We can be more inclusive.
[Inaudible].
I li I'm leaning over into that foot.
I stepped by tuck jazz hands instead.
And.
Just like that, I'm on an escalator in a full sprint.
When you say jazz hands you'll lose the argument.
It doesn't matter if the argument is for jazz hats,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if the debate is called the jazz hands debate.
Soon as you say, jazz hands yellows. Okay.
Let's just go back and let me not interrupt you.
That people would clap. Yeah, absolutely.
And that could be preventing people from going to those events,
which is a real shame. So if some theaters or some universities say,
actually we can be more inclusive and do jazz hands and said,
that'd be lovely and more people could get involved. And then what did you hear?
The guy?
Ooh, Ooh. Just.
Oh my God. That was amazing. I never heard that yet.
Oh, Ooh. Ooh. Someone is this stupid? Okay. Um, yeah.
Oh, Oh gosh. Oh gosh. Okay.
And do jazz hands and said that'd be lovely. And more people could get involved.
Oh my Oh, by, Oh.
Just hurt himself. Literally. When she said that she said it.
Oh, Oh, Oh, Oh, okay.
It's going to be okay. I just have to breathe.
I hope I die before this actually implements.
Nazi. If you clapped, I don't think there's going to be. You could get involved.
And then what would be the penalty if you clap.
What if she said tasers, tasers,
and we throw bologna at your face.
I don't think there's going to be a penalty, frankly.
I don't think anyone's going to say like.
I like how that lady came back in and like was kind of like, Oh listen,
it's not going to be okay. It's not going to be, you know,
I like how I like how she's arguing. She's arguing for the wrong thing.
And we all know it. We need to leave.
But.
If you.
Are, the guy came in again with you, of course, they're not going to leave.
They're not going to be asked to leave. We've been dealing with as a sign.
He was out at home.
Where persisting with clapping,
even though you've been requested to do something, that's been very polite.
Is it like, I think people understand.
If you're requested to do something in a specific context, you can do it.
Would it stop you Andrew?
If you were somewhere and you felt the urge to clap someone,
and yet they'd said we don't clap here.
Oh, that guy, dude, every
syllable he said was the same note. That guy was on real.
I'm not even talking about the thing anymore. The clapping and not clapping.
That guy was so angry that he was trying to control his voice with any,
he did it too hard. The other way it was, everything was one note. [inaudible].
Even though you've been requested, that's very polite. Isn't it?
People understand. If you're requested to do something in a specific context,
you can do it.
He's like, I'm so mad. Okay. Let's just calm down.
Let's not try to get a rise up my voice. Let's be, let's do this. Come on,
nodule.
Stop you Andrew. If you were somewhere and you felt the urge to clap someone,
and yet they'd said we don't clap here.
What if you went somewhere and someone found the to crap and then someone said,
wait, don't cut. Pay out. And then it says like you did it nausea.
Well, no it wouldn't.
But what we don't do is completely restructure society and completely change
societal norms in order to accommodate the sensibilities of a few people. Yeah.
It's interesting. Just reading a story about this on, uh,
on the BBC news website, um, uh,
an individual called Hannah from Weymouth endorse.
It does she struggles with loud noises like clapping. Cool.
Um, she was diagnosed with autism when she was 23. She says,
I don't agree with a ban on clapping instead let's raise awareness
of autism because this could breed resentment.
If other students start to Harbor bad feelings towards autism.
Yeah. That's smart. She's real smart. So listen. Um, okay.
Uh, banning
what w okay.
I got to Minneapolis and I went into a pub or a bar,
whatever the it was. And when I got there,
I had to get something to eat. It was like two 30.
I wanted to eat at two 30 because I didn't want to have to eat right before my
special taping, because I would have been on the mic, just like, so anyway,
you know, that's what happens. You're just like, yeah. So what's the deal with
anyway.
So I ate at the right time and when I was there,
I was in a place.
And there was a really big local, you know,
football game that was playing now.
Did it make me mad that it wasn't a professional team, even.
Yes. You, but it wasn't show where they were. They're old men cheering for,
you know, 19 year olds on a field throwing a ball around. Yes.
Did that make me feel like life was hopeless? Yes. Is it all right? Sure.
Because life rips regardless. So I was there. I ordered a Turkey club.
You know how we do. I like to keep it fresh, even though that's what I,
I get a lot. I hadn't gotten it for a long time.
So I got the Turkey club and I was like,
this is gonna be the great thing before I meal, before my meal,
before my special. Right. So this football game was going on.
People were watching it. I step in, I sit down,
I order it as soon as I start ordering people are
raw and screaming. Now, did that make me mad? Yes.
Did I feel it in my heart? Of course. Did my chest tighten up?
Yes. Was I trying to do everything I could from getting into a bad mood?
Yes. Did I somehow opened the door on the bad mood? Yeah,
I did then did I think, Oh.
I don't want to be in a bad mood while I'm taping my special.
So let's calm down. Now.
These are all the things that are going on in my head while these are just
having a good time watching the football game right there. Screaming.
Now I didn't did I mention that guy that the guy's screaming at the TV
also were in tail coats and top hats?
Did I mention it? Well, they were,
I don't know. Why were there two guys dressed the same? Yeah.
Well, I guess they were working for the hotel or some other hotel or some.
I have no idea,
but there were so loud screaming at the team and other people were like,
what the is going on now? I got,
I got mad and I was genuinely thinking,
am I one of these people that can't stand clapping? And then I thought, well,
no, I'm not. But if I was,
I would just stay home or go and deal with it.
People like this are just never going to, that's not going to happen.
What are they saying that this is what they want. They're like, well, we think,
you know, people should literally, it's like,
why don't they just get rid of their arms? And on, in all honesty,
I think that it would be a better society if they, uh, get rid of their arms,
you know, this way they don't have to, they can't clap. Right.
And then people can go, you bend it too far, one way. And by the way, this,
this just made probably, I don't know how big it is.
55,000 people saw this on the good morning Britain show. Uh, so out of 55,000,
I would say it probably made maybe 150 people sway their vote to Trump,
you know? So I just, I mean,
so silly. And then I looked on the girl's Twitter and she was like, well,
I'm getting properly dragged on, on tie. Yeah.
You're getting properly dragged spreading.